[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here so have you
guys tried to my for weak to strong and
sexy legs and abs workout which I shared
last week well this week we want to
focus on your abs and ass
I'm sure everybody would agree that
doing plank on a regular basis will give
you a tighter and stronger ass so for
the next four weeks I want you to end
your workout session with this
four-minute plank challenge do it if one
is stronger and leaner abs and also arms
we have eight plank variations will do
each workout for 30 seconds and on to
the next workout without any break don't
worry if you cannot complete the entire
four minutes just push yourself and
challenge yourself to go as far as you
can keep repeating this routine and you
will only get stronger eventually you
will be able to complete the entire four
minutes I'm also really excited to let
you know that you can find this workout
on the pump up app they have recently
launched a new feature which allows you
to create your own workout and share it
with others on the platform
it even has exercise demo estimate the
calorie burn and intensity level so I
actually created this workout on the app
such a four-minute plank for strong apps
so be sure to try this new feature and
even create your fitness plan there so
for those of you who are already part of
the pop-up family I'm sure it is keeping
you motivated and inspired for those of
you who haven't yet join the family
download the app sign up and follow me
at join us sir so guys are you ready to
do this challenge here's what I've put
together just for you like big dips
plank
cross touch plank jacks push-up the
plank
spider-man lateral plank walk plank knee
packs and reverse plank so guys I'm
going to set my timer remember to push
yourself as far as you can don't worry
if you can't complete the workout but
just remember to engage to your core
tight the new core engage your shoulders
and your own strength and just give it
your best and of course remember to
breathe and pace it really because it
will really help with your breakup so
we're going in ten seconds let's get
into a plank position
and we'll start with my favorite planet
which is plank hip dips alright so I'll
keep a plan and just tip your kick side
to side go to building left to right
that's it nice this will really work on
your core and your digs deep side to
side and again for every workout
remember breathing is very important
it's your breathing and you will be able
to bring you further and make your
performance better
next is plank cross touch three more
seconds and we want to get into a high
plank and just cross and touch okay
that's it
cross over elbows to knees elbows to me
beginners you this is difficult just
bring your knee to your elbow
alright this is another variation if not
cross touch balance look straight ahead
and just touch good keep your core
strong nice keep going
engage those core touch what's next
plank jacks in a not good just like this
plank jacks keep your shirt strong and
just jump in and out a little bit of
cardio what do you get these up slightly
plank jacks
one second slice and the fall is push up
to plank
keep going nuts plank the only down and
push yourself back up in one straight
line or do it don't push yourself good
keep your core tight and we want to come
up in one straight line as much as
possible
19:04 up very nice down whoa good few
more up one more up and just say that
strip into spider-man so side push the
other side crash near side
just let the smilin good crunch nice
keep coming
this is one of a more challenging time
but it would really work a car were to
show this and even work at the entire
body
good going guys few more crunch it
slides one more and now lets up and walk
if you have a bigger space walk into
further okay walk further
just walk depending on how much space
you have just walk left to right very
nice keep going what nice
keep walking and after this the next
back we'll do a little bit of cardio
keep going and now stop so going into up
against each other
good that's it in with your booty in you
jump up good
breathe this is we have it up and it
will and get your core and your feelings
to the front strength few more guys it
gonna lean this is how we want to end
your workout find one turn the other
side and you want to do because plan so
just down push yourself up don't push
yourself up good so again this will
engage your triceps and I'll see you
pour and squeeze the Chicopee pump as
you come back if you want lift one leg
up good people like a balance up and
change good all right you are well done
guys that was your only need to type
challenged so the next four weeks
remember to end your workout with this
challenge if you want to you can even do
it in the morning or in the evening
before you end your day
this will give you a stronger core and
also up the body
so be sure to like and share this video
with your friends as well all the rest
[Music]